I remember we all saw you at Kobe's
memorial and it was amazing because you
were very moving but you were also very
funny at the same time about Kobe it
almost seems like another lifetime ago
since this covet crisis but it must
still seem unreal to you that he's not
with us this is my toughest year and I
don't complain about anything but lost
my baby sister lost my good friend will
ever be together link and then now
people are losing their lives a lot of
people are filing for unemployment a
neighbor who lives next door been
working for Disney for 30 years got let
go the other day so you know I mean and
the conversation is just it's just just
a tough year but now I'm glad their
social media I'm glad there's DVDs and
I'm glad there's YouTube because when he
first passed away I couldn't believe it
I watched every I watched every playoff
game that we ever played I just sat in
my room I told people I don't want to
talk to anybody not just I'm like I'm
just like looking at him like okay it
can't be true because he's right there
in the screening I'm marching but you
know then he got announced you know to
the Hall of Fame and I probably won't
watch that because it was not gonna be
the same without him all the way I
watched it as if his beautiful wife
gives a speech right or if his mother
and father gives a speech on this behalf
but no I just you know if I had provided
two wishes I just wish he was there and
I wish I could take my sister to the
ceremony you know to know why should be
inducted